with everything that has come to light
this weekend and just everything that's
been gaining attention in the past few
months we feel that it's necessary for
us to address some of the fucked-up [ __ ]
that we've done in the past and today
we're gonna take accountability for us
and for everyone that is associated with
us I think one of the things I'm super
like blessed though is all of our loyal
viewers who've watched us for many many
years and they were a part of the
process of seeing us grow from like
immature young men into immature old men
and we've said a lot of stupid [ __ ] and
we've done a lot of stupid things a lot
of them wrong now looking back it's like
I should have never said or done a lot
of those things especially you know with
so many young impressionable fans and
one of the topics that's like that is
the whole council culture thing where in
the beginning I'm like what the hell is
all this all I ever do is see like
celebrities give these fake apology
videos and it's almost seems like you
see it so much that loses its meaning
yeah it's the public is mad about
something so they demand an apology
and it almost sounds like the apology is
coming from the celebrities like fear
rather than from his heart yeah and now
and especially this year like seeing all
the crazy things unfold it's just a huge
time of awakening I have a completely
different view of council culture and I
feel like there's a there's value and
there's a reason why it needs to be done
because people need to be held
accountable I think we're pretty good at
being comedians and I don't think we
have to really rely on jokes that put
other people down I always think that
sometimes you need to like take drastic
measures so that people will listen and
and with canceled culture like I don't
even know if it's canceled culture it
might just be like people speaking out
because of sexual harassment or it could
even be like people are upset about
racism and so like for me now I have a
more open perspective of like instead of
writing it off as canceled culture right
like there's a lot of things that we
have to look at
our selves and what did we do wrong or
was there ever a point in time when we
hurt people through our comedy or maybe
our opinions or maybe you know there's a
lot of the times on JK news where I'm
just workshopping an idea and I speak
out of my ass and I don't even know what
I'm saying and that's not an excuse but
because I'm not well thought out I can
be pretty hurtful and I think that's you
know inexcusable because I guess with
the platform that we have I should think
a little bit more before I say stuff and
if I did hurt people like now I want to
take a look at like what am I saying
that is where I gotta check my way of
thinking one of the things that I [ __ ]
up on was I made the decision to put on
blackface to play a character for a skit
I was stupid and I didn't see how wrong
it was but now looking back it's
something that I'm actually really
ashamed of and even addition to that
like in a bunch of videos we've said the
n-word a bunch of times and the old
excuse was like oh that's that's how we
grew up or you know when you grow up in
the hood everyone says it's okay but
it's not okay you know and we have like
all these videos of just all kinds of
things of almost not violations but a
lot of it was hurtful to a lot of
hurtful to a lot of people and a lot of
instances well some are big and blatant
and some are just yeah really small and
mild but none of them are okay and so I
think it's important that I apologize
for every single one of those I think
it's important that I acknowledge that
those videos are bad and I'm ashamed
that those are bad and that I changed
the way that I made content from this
point oh and what really sucks right now
is our entire country feels like it's in
a bad marriage like in a marriage you're
supposed to love each other and you're
supposed to be dedicated to the
well-being of each other
the biggest thing that's getting in the
way of understanding is not
communicating having a strong ego and
not willing to listen and I think in
order for us to fix that we have to be
able to talk to each other and put out
you go aside and go to therapy and be
willing to learn hold ourselves
a bowl and make change afterwards I went
out to support BLM with Asian
organizations and we went out to March
and and to me I just want to show up for
people out there that it's all of us
against racism and even though I've
might have been someone who's
perpetuated racism in the past that's
not my goal in the future and I want to
learn from that and to show that I think
it's very it's very important for people
like us people with an audience to speak
out against it and and stand against it
and show physically that we're here to
support a new world and a new society
that racism is just doesn't exist here
and one of the things I recently learned
from the past shoot last week is
complacency is actually supporting
racism and it's not enough to just stand
by and go hey I'm being neutral and I'm
being passive and I don't want to get
involved in order to fight racism
everyone has to actually take an action
and take a stand and move against the
opposite direction and that's what I'm
committed to do that's what Jo is
committed to do and that's what JK as a
company is committed to do for the non
black fans out there who who are
watching and you want to show support
like thanks but do it silently we want
to leave platform and space for our
black fans to speak so in the comments
section we would love to hear what you
have to say we're also committed to
donating to the n-double-a-cp Legal
Defense Fund and we're gonna be doing
our part by researching and continuously
finding organizations that we can help
in support we're sorry it took so long
for us to realize but now I think this
is day one of our growth and you know
from this it can only go up where we're
gonna continuously learn from our
mistakes